je m'appelle cédric je suis comédien il
vient de passer le casting lui redonner
pas de malheur à la base j'étais pas le
premier joueur à l'eau pour moi made man
c'est toi
mais grâce à un petit coup de pouce du
destin
badman c'est moi
le premier super héros
français
bref tout allait au mieux jusqu'à cette
fameuse nuit
où j'ai perdu la mémoire
c'est pas
bonjour batman batman
je crois que mon frère se prend pour le
personnage de son film de super héros
il est parti terminé sa mission
écoutez moi bien parce que je vous le
dirai qu'une seule fois
[Musique]
c'est compris
pour le rattraper avant qu'il fasse une
connerie
[Musique]
pardon
celui-là cantonales coincé il va
apprendre très très cher
je peux pas faire prendre des risques
c'est enfin et
comment de tous les spermatozoïdes il
était arrivé le premier
[Musique]
à
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis désolé c'est terriblement gênant
je comprends mieux pourquoi les super
héros mais de leur slip par dessus leur
pantalon